And now we already know that we can solve vertex cover using a search tree.
So we started with the original graph,
and I'm now going to use again the search tree where we
branch into only 3 different possibilities.
We know it's not the best possible one, but it will be easier to understand the
rest this way, but it also works for the more complicated search trees.
So then on the next level, we again branched into
3 different possibilities on each level and so on.
And we said that the search tree had a size of N half
and the total number of solutions that we looked at in the search tree
was 3 to the power of N half,
which as you remember was about 1.734 to the power of N.
Now I would like you to quickly think about the following:
So as you'll remember, at each level of the search tree,
we're looking at an edge where the 2 end points have not yet had an assignment,
and we're branching into 3 cases,
this one, this one, and this one.
So now it's a very easy quiz actually.
So how many vertices are added each time
we go one level deeper into the tree?
At least 1, at least 2, exactly 1, exactly 2,
or is this something that actually depends on the structure of the input graph?